[Music]
hey wisecrack Jared here full disclosure
this video is made possible by the
people over at Ferb we've been fans of
the mondo show Happy Tree Friends for a
while so when verve reached out to us
and asked us to check out the new mondo
show gary and his demons streaming
exclusively on Verve we were pretty
excited and five episodes in we couldn't
help but notice a lot of similarities to
two otherwise crack favors Archer and
this show that we've mentioned maybe
once or twice before don't hate one
particular moment stood out to us as
particularly zeitgeist II when it comes
to murdering people I guess you could
say ya hacked what would you say I guess
you could say you're Huck that's what
you're gonna say that's not what I was
gonna say pretty sure it is oh it's not
your whole personality is hooks man
there's other things you can say alright
which reminded us of this oh my god
would you give it a rest
[Applause]
does that scan this subversion of hero
one-liners got us thinking why is this
kind of humour so prevalent these days
is there something more going on here
that says something about our modern
social condition and as we watched more
we realized that was just the tip of the
iceberg so if you haven't seen Gary and
his demons yet check out Verve Co slash
wisecrack for a 30-day free trial and
join us as we impart on a time-honored
wisecrack tradition over-explaining a
joke for the sake of social commentary
one thing we've noticed lately is a
particular trend in comedy subjecting
the fantastic to the mundane in Rick and
Morty the fanciful tale of Jack and the
Beanstalk is taken down a peg
when the narrative becomes mired in
legal proceedings the horrifying Freddy
Krueger has the same marital woes and
performance anxiety as your average slob
and even the post-apocalypse still has
suburban domestic spats ding-ding-ding
Wow everybody here that in Archer the
secret agent fantasy of blowing up and
womanizing is subjected to the realities
of expense reports
some serious discrepancies in your
account no Cyril I'm sure you wouldn't
use operational funds for personal
expenses
[Music]
HR most of my jobs dealing with sexual
harassment complaints against mr. Archer
and hearing loss
what does bury what we don't have any
pepper
earplugs you idiot you know how bad that
is for your eardrums Gary and his demons
does the same subjecting demon hunting
to the mundane eighties of office life
and sock puppets you'd be comfortable
talking to my friend sock guy what hi
suck okay why does this comedy work so
well and why now or at least for adult
cartoon viewers between the ages of 18
and 34 well to be overly dramatic one
could say it's because our dreams are
dead still with me
good because to understand why we're
gonna have to dive into the philosophy
of humor there are a few major theories
of humor out there but one that popped
up only a few hundred years ago is
incongruity basically the idea that
humor arises from the discrepancy
between our expectations and reality I
mean what is a punchline if not the
subversion of our expectations smoke pot
and then talk about how one day maybe we
could be on Conan together yesterday but
there's one philosopher who takes this
further arguing that humor arises from
the incongruity between our notion of
ourselves as humans and the subversion
of that notion by the mechanical nature
of our lives while this theory is a bit
antiquated we can use it to help us
understand humor today
in 1904 onry birds in theorized that the
source of humor was the mechanical
encrusted upon the human writing during
the Industrial Revolution
Bergson said when we laugh because
someone falls it's not necessarily their
misfortune that we find funny but the
spectacle of a machine malfunctioning in
this case our bodies for example take
the classic prank of pulling a chair out
from under a friend about to sit they
fall on their ass hilarity ensues
according to Bergson we laughed because
an action as routine as sitting down is
basically the body on autopilot seeing
that habitual motion fail is what
generates the lulls and while this kind
of falling on your ass humor certainly
predates machines we can still think of
it in terms of mechanical rigidity
against human flexibility it's probably
no coincidence that Bergson was writing
when factories and machines reshaped
modern life more than 30 years later
Charlie Chaplin would in some ways
embody elements of Bergson's theory in
modern times were the intrusion of
mechanization onto the human is put
front and center if modern times was so
popular was it because he struck a nerve
with people's relationship to machines
for Chaplin it's not just that humans
are acting like machines but have also
become entangled in a society of
machines which brings us to modern day
we no longer feel our sense of self
threatened by physical machines but
another kind of machine
you see Bergson's formulation has
evolved humor isn't just the machine
encrusted upon the human but society
encrusted along the human the component
parts of society state and corporate
bureaucracy cultural expectations all
act like a kind of machine one that
happens to simultaneously feed us dreams
and tear them away from us the
discrepancy between our fantasies that
helped us cope with reality and the
reality that forsakes those dreams is
the new engine of humor in 2018 Gary and
his demons imagines a chosen demon
hunter as a sad-sack working stiff who
can't even retire I realized why I mean
all the time it's cus my job sucks and
my life could sucks more than anyone
elses and that's not navel-gazing that
is the truth
demons have to face being in or out like
fashion trends he's the hot new mirror
monster running his mouth about how the
old guard is out of touch Bloody Mary
dates back to the 1500s
I am mirror monster
and in Archer even the exciting world of
espionage won't take your mind off your
flex account I forgot to spend the
balance of my goddamn flex a guy and
while Rick may be the only one above it
all
I mean he's not bogged down by expense
reports and bureaucracy and bureaucrats
his arch-nemesis are a bunch of
himselves that reduce other versions of
himself to factory workers and Stooges
the whole joke of simple rick is
revealing the real nature of escapist
fantasy as just another cog in the
soulless machine come home to the unique
flavor of shattering the grand illusion
come home to simple Rick and it's not
just these three shows this kind of
humor is everywhere the good place
imagines an afterlife full of legal
arbitration and algorithms when your
time on earth has ended we calculate the
total value of your life using our
perfectly accurate measuring system only
the people with a very highest scores
the true cream of the crop get to come
here to the good place one punch man
imagine superheroing as a dumb
bureaucratic game mired in red tape and
the sleeper hit soon-to-be TV show what
we do in the shadows envisions
frightening vampires fighting over banal
roommate issues vampires don't do dishes
to return to Bergson if we find all this
funny it's because we're confronted with
a mirror of our own lives more than just
laughing at bodies as machines we laugh
when we imagine people as mere
instruments of a greater machine Bergson
gives the example of a person who
performs their duty not like a human but
like a machine he cites a story he found
in a newspaper a large steamer was
wrecked off the coast of France after
courageously rushing to save the
passengers the customs officers didn't
ask if the survivors were okay but
rather immediately asked if they had
anything to declare the customs officers
were not acting as humans but mere
instruments of a larger bureaucracy and
this is exactly what shows like Archer
Gary and his demons and sometimes Rick
and Morty rely on how we've become mere
instruments of a larger game it puts on
display the incongruity between the way
we imagine the
ought to be in the way it really is
because of this discrepancy we no longer
live in a world where we can stomach be
cheery idealism of heroes past but have
to deconstruct the fantasy at every turn
because our fantasies have been
deconstructed we can't imagine much of
anything without wanting to think of
what is pulling its strings take the
superhero one-liner once a source of
catharsis it became it now needs to be
exposed as a tired cliché so we get this
[Music]
you should know that is an original and
this Gillette should be ready with the
transdermal solution of the most
powerful accident known to man hey damn
it I had something for this Marvel
movies can't sell superheroes without
constantly undercutting the seriousness
of what they're doing Deadpool is one of
the most popular superheroes by virtue
of not being a hero at all and things
like cinemasins draw humor from
subjecting films to a level of cold hard
logic that they weren't even built for
this leads us to the second marker of
modern humor a broken protagonist now
this certainly isn't new Jerry Seinfeld
did it over 20 years ago but instead of
looking up to Burt Reynolds we now
admire a broken version of Burt Reynolds
or a broken van helsing or a broken Doc
Brown and then there's something like
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia a show
that according to creator Glenn Howerton
shows what the American Dream looks like
when you fail even the notion of doing
good deeds is shat on relishing in the
collateral damage that often comes with
being a quote good guy our demon hunter
amputates an orphan by accident and
tries to be a nicer person before
realizing it's pointless
you came oh I knew you cared about me
you are a good guy yeah similarly Morty
tries to save an interdimensional being
from assassination only to discover it
wants to exterminate all life
carbon-based life is
to all higher life to us you are what
you would call a disease and has to kill
it himself
Rick highlights the futility of
do-gooding when he says what about the
reality where Hitler cured cancer Morty
the answer is don't think about it and
the entire premise of Archer is to
explore these self-obsessed
eccentricities of the people who are
supposed to keep us safe at night
to summarize we were promised jetpacks
and hoverboards and because we never got
them
we have no fantasies no heroes and some
serious skepticism about doing good and
now the best sense of pleasure we can
get is collectively reflecting on that
sense of disappointment now that's not
to say we're completely without dreams
instead of dreaming of nicer cars and
the perfect relationship which shirt
definitely still happens we also get
gratification by relishing in the
utterly mundane would you rather get
embroiled in a particularly nasty Ponzi
scheme or go on a date with Trevor from
school things like the Roy game or this
are barely even science fiction she's
obsessed with her new virtual bouncer
game real fun you on the list
nice try pal the back of the line is it
any different than the wildly popular
job simulator game where one pretends to
be a robot poorly re-enacting mundane
office work or clicker games but is
everything hopeless of course not
yes we wise crackers can sometimes seem
like curmudgeons but hey that's what
happens when you read philosophy bro but
I promise there's still hope
like my dog woody look at that baby face
muffin man Oh Oh or for instance I went
to this place that took my two favorite
sauces hummus and garlic sauce and
turned it into one sauce it pretty much
shattered my worldview so look how can
you fixate on the hopelessness of the
modern condition when there are still
breakthroughs made every day in sauce
technology and for more good
old-fashioned distractions check out new
episodes of Garry and his demons on
Verve every Sunday by going to Verve Co
slash wisecrack whether you're online or
offline you can watch Garry and a bunch
of other great animated shows on verb
like freakazoid bravest warriors deep
space 69 and bee and puppycat also if
you're an anime
ferb has the best subbed and dubbed
shows including my hero academia Dragon
Ball super black clover and food Wars
thanks to verb for giving us this
opportunity and as always guys thanks
for watching peace
[Music]